لحظه حدوث الزلزال كانت كل احلام سكان هذه
الخيام تتلخص في نجاتهم ونجاه اكبر عدد من
ذويهم وبعد النجاه صاروا يحلمون بخيمه
كهذه تاويهم وتقي اجسادهم بردا الليالي
وحر الايام مرحبا هذا هنا صالون يعتبر
يعني شويه اغراض حاطينه هون لبسه للاولاد
هذا هو محل منامي هاي هي الخيمه الموجوده
ساكن ببيت بيت راح كله بالكامل راحوا لي
ثلاث اولاد
وطلعت زوجتي هاي زوجتي وهي بنتي طلعت من
الانقاذ وطلعت عمي واحد بياخد راحته ببيته
ما متلخيمه يعني هذا المؤاخذه بده يتحمم
بيته في حمام هون بدك تروح لهنيك حمام
مشترك حاويات كانت تجوب العالم محمله
بالبضائع تحولت الى بيوت يحلم بها ضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا وهي تبدو لهم قصورا
مقارنه مع الخيام
بنشو
[موسيقى]
انا اعمل في الميناء واقود اله رفع
الحاويات لمده 30 عاما واليوم وبعد انهيار
بيتي بسبب زلزال صارت هذه الحاويه هي
منزلي هنا اعيش رفقه زوجتي وهذه اغراضنا
ينام برفقتنا خمسه اشخاص من عائلتنا
مرحبا بكم في بيت الجديد هنا نعيش وهذا هو
مطبخي الوضع صعب اتمنى الحصول على مسكن
لائق في اقرب وقت
لن يتوقف حلم قاطني هذه البيوت المؤقته
هنا وان طال البقاء انه التشبث بالحياه
يجعل الاحلام تكبر يوما بعد يومه هذا هو
حال الناجين من كارثه الزلزال الاكثر
تدميرا في تاريخ تركيا الحديث عبد القادر
خربوش العربيه